[Laughter]
tegan loves playing in the water with
her brothers miles and ethan
they know little of the climate-driven
water pressures facing our towns and
cities
but their mum janet does the shrinking
ardingly reservoir supplies her home one
of thousands that will be impacted by
next week's hosepipe ban in the south
east well as someone who lives in a
house with many people at one time we
always have our attention on how much
energy we use anyway and the water
consumption on a normal basis and that's
when we have no other concerns or
reasons to be concerned so we our
attention is already on that and
obviously now
with sometimes six people in the house
today we've got eight people in the
house everyone needs to shower
wash their stuff have the dishes cleaned
they've got kids on school holidays as
well so it's being cautious not using
too much water
dudley's home overlooks hardingly
reservoir
extra demand during the long hot spell
means water levels are much lower than
expected in a normal year
the water
would be as high as that rail
until
about june from then on it goes down a
bit a bit yeah
and very rarely does it go at
this step
southeast water and welsh water will
join southern water with host pipe bands
affecting millions of households across
the uk
the government making its first
intervention wants water companies to
act with more urgency
the hosepipe ban is a short-term
emergency measure it's designed to
protect water supplies and get us
through the rest of this hot summer but
what water companies will really be
thinking about is the future as climate
patterns change
and weather like this becomes more
frequent
angry customers have been taking to
social media to urge their local water
companies to do more to fix leaks and
stop wastage
this leak in hull was reported to
yorkshire water
and this in farmer was reported to
southern water whose customers have
already been banned from using host
pipes
from april 2020 to march 2021
water companies lost 2.3 million litres
of water to leaks every day
that's a nearly three percent rise on
the previous year
five water companies reported higher
than expected leakage levels including
yorkshire water and anglian water
there is not one single thing which will
solve the risk of droughts
the national infrastructure commission
has said that we should really be
proceeding on three fronts and roughly
equally on those three planets one
is reducing leakage two is reducing
water demand
and three is making more water sources
available through investment in
strategic infrastructure
a host pipe ban might seem like just a
short term inconvenience
but the warnings are there
of longer drier weather and not only
during hot summer spells
a future that will impact generations to
come
much more severely
ashish joshi sky news in surrey